first instinctive step when you're
graphing this now I've told you I told
you in the first case to differentiate
and then to graph okay
so that's kind of guiding you in one
direction so I used to be able to say
those words and no one would give me any
weird looks and now it's back my English
language anyway okay so I'm gonna
differentiate it to stop all right now
um you guys know that when you
differentiate itself to which of when
you're differentiating something you
should always simplify as much as you
can first because differentiating tends
to make things more complicated
especially when you've got a question
like this right so for instance you know
if I gave you you know y equals x cubed
minus 1 on X ok you would know to
simplify this right rather than do with
question rule you could do it because
you rule you might get the wrong right
answer but you might easily get the
wrong one because question rules so ever
okay so how would you say goodbye that X
minus 1 over X and that's much easier to
do with ok now in this case it's not
quite as obvious because your log
function at the top and you've got
something which doesn't seem to mix with
it it's true enough you can't simplify
that like you can this but there is so
simplifying to do if you remember your
log laws which we looked at last week
right now when you think of this okay
I've got to deal with the question rule
I'm not gonna get rid of my question but
I can make it a much simpler question
right because at the moment not not only
am I gonna have to do with U and V I've
got to do with you - and V - and when
you look at that you like owner I've got
Chris rule and then I've got chain rule
inside that right because it's log of
montrose tax but log about a function of
X okay so in order to avoid that you
remember your laws and you can say log
of x squared right
that's a power right the index I can
bring it up the front making people
so I can say that's to log X yes is that
okay and that's to log X over X the
whole thing now one of the advantage of
doing that is you already in the
previous question you already worked out
the derivative for this right so if you
want to work out the derivative for to
log X you just take the previous riveted
and you double it right so what was the
derivative forgot the first question
what did you get you have I have a root
down somewhere hold on mm-hmm I think we
got yeah let's say 1 minus log x over
there's out V squared on the bottom yeah
check out yeah okay so since I've got a
2 out the front this from the previous
question I should put a 2 at the front
here ok now you're trying to graph right
so why is the derivative useful to us
when we graph it because I can use it to
find stationary points right so I would
say therefore stationary points exist
when the derivative is 0 right by the
way I know it it's often a pain people
like oh do I have to write this kind of
say why that's just equal to 0 it's not
going you could probably find the right
answer but it's it's less logical you're
saying yeah right you're just
introducing new things without
explaining what how long does it take
you to write that really I'm so improved
you're saying yeah it also helps you
work out if you've got any problems you
can go back and your answer will be much
more readable not just for the mark of
it for you so we can solve it I could
disregard my denominator because it
doesn't matter what the denominator is I
just need to make sure it's not 0 that
gives me 1 minus log X is equal to 0 so
log X is equal to 1 right and at this
point just remember what Ln natural log
means it means log base E right and in
the past few lessons we've been going
back and forth between the Log form of
an equation and the index form okay and
this is a classic example of what you
want to use the index for because here X
is e to the power of 1 which is just
okay now before I leave off here okay
I sort of pulled a bit of a shifty on
you and I don't know if any of you
noticed right what we did this okay and
I used my logos to make things simpler
and to get my derivative I actually
changed the function significantly okay
it's what I did a little bit like if I
gave you the function y equals x right
and said well surely this is the same as
x squared over X isn't it why shouldn't
I be able to you know interchange
between these and the answer is almost
right if I were to graph each of these
two graphs they would have overlap sorry
overlap for most of the way in this case
except for one point right this graph
would have a hole in it at the origin
okay because X can equal zero and the
same way these two graphs if I were to
graph them they would overlap but the
exception is a little bigger than this
it's not just one point that I'm missing
when I go from here to here I've
actually locked off half the graph I've
locked off half of it can anyone tell me
why oh okay so when you're thinking
about log functions right
y equals log X okay think about the
domain of this thing domain and range
yeah
this graph looks like this okay so the
domain is X is going to be greater than
zero so whatever's in there yes but when
you're graphing y equals log of x
squared if I Square this that means I
can square this x squared is greater
than zero when you think about what that
looks like
where is this graph greater than zero
well for all real values except for here
right so importantly not only can I go
over here but X can be negative right
you can put negative numbers in here and
they're just fine right because they get
squared and all come down to watch okay
so therefore when I think about how I go
from here to here I've walked off half
the graph and not just any half right
this top thing here is an
the function okay anytime you get X
Squared's you'll get an even function
okay down here I've got an odd function
when I divided when I take the product
or the question right oven off one by
even in an odd function the result would
be line okay so I should be expecting
some symmetry here right if I've got a
stationary point at x equals E I should
have another good stationary point at x
equals well if it's an odd function
symmetrically the other way so it should
be minus it now you could see that if
you didn't do my trick and if you
differentiate it properly and use the
chain rule okay because instead of this
line you would get to here let's see you
have log of x squared because each one
right so then you take well okay in that
case I can take two values for X right I
can take either of these and they would
work okay so that's why my own that's
how much stationary points are gonna be
you can put them in and find out
whatever y-coordinate are but they're
not that important to me at the moment
because it's enough for me to work out
and generally what the shape of this
thing will look like so
let's just finish it up there's no way
this is a vertical asymptote where x
equals zero right you can see that from
the denominator okay there is a
horizontal asymptote where is it at at Y
is zero right no how do I know that you
think about what happens at the
extremities of this graph
okay log all of something and X right
which one is growing faster a long curve
looks like this
we call that lorry bigger right and X is
leaning up so we call that linear growth
right so which one is getting bigger
over time when I look at you know
infinities okay the denominator is
getting bigger they're actually both
pretty slow it's kind of like two grumpy
old men fighting long but one graph your
men is slightly grumpier than the other
one so we want a bit faster so in this
case that's the denominator okay so it's
still growing faster if this is growing
fast the whole thing will tend toward
zero which is why I've got this
asymptote so y equals zero x equals zero
I found two stationary quite one should
be at E and the other should be n minus
eight and when you start to put in some
values I think we're coming in like this
on one side okay you can test out a
value large positive values are just
gonna be just above the assets right
okay but because I know this is
stationary point I know I must come from
below and whip down okay and because we
said this is an odd function
I should get the opposite kind of shape
to finish I would find the locations of
those and that would be